this is my favorite spot on the Holy
Land the coastline of the Sea of Galilee
close to the biblical site of tapka
whenever I come to Israel I always try
to find a few minutes to sit here and
meditate on the ministry of Jesus
the reason is that this is one of those
very few places where little has changed
since those heady days in the First
Century A.D or the first century in the
Common Era as Scholars call it today
just look at this Rocky Beach and you
will see a Vista that is very close to
what Jesus saw when he came here away
from the crowds to have a moment by
himself
we know he often did this because the
Evangelist Mark tells us so
in the morning when it was still very
dark he got up and went out to a
deserted place and there he prayed and
Simon and his companions hutted for him
when they found him they said to him
everyone is searching for you
we can imagine Jesus sitting here
praying and meditating glad to be away
from all the commotion and then Simon
Peter has to come and drag him away
but actually as we will see later on
this is a very important moment in
Jesus's Ministry the moment when he
decides to take his message outside of
Capernaum his home base
to the surrounding villages
some 2000 years later Jesus is still a
dominant figure in many civilizations
including ours which is why Christianity
is today the world's largest religion
with some two and a half billion
followers that is an incredible success
and it All Began here on this spot on
the shores of the Sea of Galilee
[Music]
today there are more than 40
000 different Christian denominations in
the world
by comparison Judaism knows three main
branches today Reform Judaism
conservative Judaism and Orthodox
Judaism which has several movements in
itself
when we look at Islam the second largest
faith in the world with two billion
followers that tradition is divided into
two main branches the Sunni who make up
around 87 percent and the Shia who make
up around 13 percent
so even though these two religions have
certain divisions within themselves they
don't come anywhere near the
fragmentation of the Christian Movement
in the United States alone there are
more than 200 Christian denominations
how is that possible
if we all claim to walk in the footsteps
of Jesus shouldn't there be some
agreement about what that means exactly
well that's the question that inspired
this series one reason as we will see is
that Jesus ministry was very short not
more than 18 months to judge by the
stories of the synoptic gospels which
describe his life in a very similar way
that means that for a full generation
after his life on Earth his memory was
kept Alive by Oral Traditions before
they were committed to documents that
have survived to this day such as the
Gospels
that is one reason why even during the
rise of Christianity the traditional
strand formulated by Paul of Tarsus the
idea of universal salvation through
faith in Christ's sacrifice on the cross
was challenged by other Christian
factions among these were Gnostic
Christians who focused on Jesus's
teachings rather than the role of his
crucifixion as an agency of redemption
another source of contention was the
nature of Jesus the synoptic gospels
seek to present Jesus as the Jewish
Messiah the mashyach an iconic figure
who would liberate his people from
foreign occupation and restore a land
ruled by the laws of God
Paul on the other hand found many
converts among Gentiles in the
Mediterranean who had no idea what a
messiah was
in response Paul and other ministers
like him changed the focus of Jesus's
Ministry from that of a messiah to the
universal Redemptive role of the son of
God but this raised all sorts of
questions among his Gentile followers
who were of course raised in a
polytheistic culture of Greece and Rome
How could a man be a mortal human being
and a god at the same time
that question proved irresistible to the
Greek mind which loved to debate a
paradox such as this
from the 4th Century onwards these
debates ripped the early church apart
and led to the splintering of
Christianity followed by the great
schism of 1054 between east and west
and then five centuries later Europe
itself was deeply divided when Martin
Luther launched the Reformation
the same is true for colonial America
for example the New England colonies
were largely made up of a number of
English religious groups including
Quaker and Puritan sects
the south on the other hand retained
much of the class distinctions that had
ruled the Anglican Society of Great
Britain by contrast the middle colonies
were far more egalitarian in scope
because of their mix of French German
and Irish immigrants many of whom were
catholic
the religious differences between the
colonies mattered little
while they fought a war to secure
independence from Great Britain
but the Revolutionary War also led to
the destruction of many churches which
caused a brain drain of Methodist and
Anglican clergy who fled back to England
the result was a religious vacuum which
gave rise to a new and more indigenous
form of American Christianity of
believers who met intents for an
improvised combination of singing
preaching and prayer
thus was born a new Faith tradition that
of evangelicalism
[Music]
as for myself
I was raised in a Catholic Family but as
a Biblical scholar I have often lectured
at Lutheran Methodist and Episcopal
churches
in the process I have found that there
are many things that we as Christians in
the 21st century have in common these
insights are what inspired me to develop
this series not just for believers but
for everyone who is interested in the
figure of the historical Jesus
and one of these insights is the
question why are Christians so divided
in America and indeed the world
is it because our different cultures as
well as our politics have moved us apart
and if that's true what can we do about
it how can each side whether right left
or Center claim to follow in the
footsteps of Jesus and what can
Christians do to heal this Great Divide
the answer to me is quite simple by
returning to the very things that Jesus
talked about by trying to understand
why he began his ministry and what he
aimed to achieve
that is the purpose of this series
what we are going to do is try to
reconstruct the historical Jesus from
the very beginning but stripped of all
the church doctrines and political ideas
that have accumulated around his
presence over the past 2000 years
is that a dangerous thing to do
should Christians be worried about their
faith while watching this series that is
a question I'm often asked when I
lecture about topics like the Jesus of
History versus the Christ of faith
people ask is there a difference between
the two
and the answer is well yes of course
as we will see the Jesus of history is
an incredibly inspiring figure but not
yet equipped with a theological Legacy
of centuries of church teachings
but are the differences between the two
essential and here the answer is no
the fundamental facts of both figures
are the same look I've been researching
the historical Jesus for over 30 years
and I can tell you that for me as a
practicing Christian my faith has been
strengthened by that research
I have found that the historical Jesus
as a fully developed human being filled
with the spirit of the Divine is an
incredibly powerful figure in my life
that is why I believe that all branches
of the Christian Community can only come
together by returning to the essential
teachings of his ministry
and the first thing that we will
discover is that this ministry unfolded
in a crisis very similar to the one we
face today
the daily news feed of thousands of
people who are out of work who are ill
who are facing eviction struggling to
feed their families is a world that
Jesus would have recognized as we will
see
along the way we will visit all the
principal places described in the
gospels moving from a small First
Century Village like Nazareth to
sephorus where Jesus and his father
Joseph worked on building a new capital
city
to Bethany on the Jordan where Jesus
joined the movement of John the Baptist
and then to the key sides of his
ministry including Capernaum bethsaida
corazim magdala and other places outside
of lower Galilee such as banyas
[Music]
next we will follow him to Jerusalem for
Passover of 30 A.D we will reconstruct
the chronology of events that led from
his visit to the temple to the room of
the last supper from the place of his
arrest in Gethsemane to his indictment
In The House of the high priest Caiaphas
and from The Trial presided by Pontius
Pilate to his crucifixion and the Easter
events
and finally we will follow the spread of
early Christianity throughout the
Eastern Mediterranean and Beyond
on our journey we will be guided by a
number of ancient documents some of
which you probably know and some of
which may be new to you of course that
includes a critical analysis of the four
gospels as well as other gospels that
were not included in the New Testament
now when I say critical analysis that
doesn't mean we're going to examine the
gospels in any negative or disrespectful
way what it means is that we will use a
set of tools often used by historians to
understand the sources the form and the
development of these texts
that is particularly important because
the earliest gospel manuscripts that we
have today date from the third and
fourth centuries that means that there
is a gap of at least 250 years between
the life of Jesus and the date of these
texts
by contrast we know a lot more about
Hebrew scripture the Christian Old
Testament in Jesus day thanks to the
Dead Sea Scrolls
those Day from the 2nd Century BC to the
first century 80. so we can actually
read the Hebrew Bible
the way Jesus knew it
of course the gospels included in the
New Testament will be very important for
our story the oldest Gospel is actually
the one written by the author we know as
Mark
using a very basic form of Greek known
as coin
but the actual text of the Gospel does
not mention a mark nor does it identify
its author
Church tradition has identified the
author with John Mark a friend of Paul
who visited the community at colossae
a growing consensus of scholars believe
that Mark's gospel was written in Rome
by a member of the Jewish Community
there possibly in the wake of the
outbreak of the first Jewish war between
66 and 70 A.D
[Music]
this Revolt was prompted by the cruelty
and Corruption of the Roman government
in Judea
but Jews living in Rome would have been
at pains to stress their patriotic
allegiance to Rome rather than to the
rebels in Judea
and so what we see is that a major theme
of Mark's gospel is to shift the blame
for Jesus's death from the Roman prefect
ponceus pilate to the Jewish crowds
attending his trial
it is Mark who first arranged the acts
and sayings of Jesus in a narrative that
propels the Ark of the story toward the
climax of the crucifixion
the other gospels followed his example
now the author of The Gospel of Luke was
probably a Greek speaking Jew who
accompanied Paul on his journey to
Greece
Luke is also credited with writing the
book of The Acts of the Apostles and
this suggestion is usually accepted by
most Scholars however neither the gospel
itself nor acts provide a clue to the
identity of its writer so here too there
is no certainty about its authorship
more than likely the person we call Luke
was a scribe living in the diaspora who
was charged by a local christian
community with writing a book about
Jesus based on the available oral
traditions
Matthew is often identified as the tax
collector named Levi whom Jesus found at
the customs house in Capernaum and who
subsequently joined him as an apostle
but the gospel text never actually
identifies its author what's more
Matthew's gospel is written in a very
elegant Greek that suggests the hand of
a highly educated scribe rather than a
tax collector in a small Township like
Capernaum
both the Gospel of Luke and that of
Matthew were written some two decades
after that of Mark
in fact Matthew and Luke copied as much
as 60 percent of Mark's story in their
own narrative
but both evangelists also used another
source which is now lost but which
Scholars have been tried to reconstruct
it is known as skew based on the German
word cuele which means Source the thing
we must remember is that our modern
understanding of authorship did not
exist in antiquity
to readers in ancient times What
mattered was not the man who wielded the
pen but the authority with which he
wrote or the literary tradition with
which he identified himself
what we do know is that it is unlikely
that any of the evangelists were members
of Jesus's Entourage or witnessed the
events they wrote about
they lived in different cities outside
of Roman Palestine and relied on a
variety of sources both in oral and
written form which had probably been
circulating for several decades
that is why the gospel accounts do not
always agree with one another
that is particularly true for the Gospel
of John
since most Scholars date The Gospel of
John to the last decade of the first
century it is difficult to imagine that
it could have been written by someone
who was a member of Jesus's Circle
the gospel itself makes no Claim about
its authorship but it does say that its
account is based on the testimony of the
Apostle John whom Jesus loved and who is
testifying to these things and has
written them so it's quite possible that
the gospel is based on an oral or
written tradition associated with this
apostle
you know John's gospel is a very
sophisticated document elegantly written
and inspired by neo-platonic ideas
Jesus emerges as a Transcendent being
who manifests himself in terms like the
light of the world and the bread of life
it also contains many long monologues
that do not appear in the other Gospels
with this Jesus we are far removed from
the very human down to earth figure who
inhabits the gospel of Mark
but there are other first century
sources about Jesus one very important
source is the historian Josephus he was
born around 37 A.D just a few years
after the crucifixion into a Jewish
Priestly family in Jerusalem
30 years later when the first Jewish war
against the Romans began he was pressed
into Service as an officer leading a
regiment of Jewish resistance Fighters
while fighting in Galilee he was
defeated by the Roman Legions under the
command of General Vespasian but he
saved his life by foretelling that this
General Would One Day become emperor
sure enough in July of 69 A.D the
spacious Legions pronounced him
imperator
Josephus was released and eventually
followed the emperor to Rome where he
wrote a book about the Jewish War
he later published another more detailed
book about Jewish history
even though Josephus is not particularly
interested in early Christians his books
are incredibly valuable for
understanding the world of first century
Galilee and Judea he even writes about
John the Baptist as well as Jesus
another important source is the Jewish
mishnah
the mishna is a record of debates
between rabbis about the application of
the Torah the Jewish law in everyday
life
although the book was first compiled
around 200 A.D many scholars believe
that some of its case studies go back to
the first century
the mishna is important because it
touches on many topics that Jesus and
the Pharisees debate in the gospels such
as the observance of the Sabbath ritual
Purity marriage laws and the role of
women in society
two supplements to the mishnah the
bharata and the tosafta even include
references to yeshu the Nazarene as
Jesus is called and finally and perhaps
more importantly there is archeology
particularly in the last 10 to 15 years
biblical archeology in the holy land has
produced discoveries that profoundly
affect our understanding of the
historical Jesus many of the most
exciting discoveries were made in
Galilee notably in magdala the city of
Mary Magdalene and other towns around
the Sea of Galilee all of which we will
visit in this series
[Music]
who was the historical Jesus and will
the answer help us to heal the great
divisions in the Christian Community
to find out please join me as we embark
on our great journey
walking with the historical Jesus in the
Holy Land
from his birth to his ministry in
Galilee and his passion in Jerusalem